[Music]
andrea welcome to simulation
thank you so much i have to admit i was
a little bit nervous when you asked me
to do it
which of course means for me that i must
so i'm very happy to be here
i love that vibe right off the bat it's
like if i'm feeling a little bit of
discomfort
let's investigate must go there
[Laughter]
must investigate discomfort yeah
it's true it's really true but you're so
uh relaxed and easy and you know what i
watched
every episode that you recorded with
somebody from nls so far and
yeah i mean it was just it's just so off
the cuff and
easy going and i don't know i i just
really loved the whole vibe
it just made me realize oh yeah just be
yourself
do your thing and there's room for all
of it that's what you
do you make a lot of room for a lot of
things
to happen and you don't put a lid on
very much
and i i love that oh such a good way to
put it
yeah yeah i'm i'm really grateful i'm
really grateful that you've put
so much love into what we've put love
into
which is producing the the content you
guys can find the
no limits society conversations playlist
on the channel and we'll also be adding
andreas to it as well which is awesome
[Laughter]
and that you you caught it it's not
it's not always so fast that
people can catch what happens
in other people's
essence you caught it really fast
which is just total flow
and total love and total space
for the exact firework the exact aroma
that emerges from the dialectic to just
shine
yeah yeah yeah that's one of my talents
that's one of my unique
uh talents and and natural
things that i come with like what do
they call it um your puzzle piece
you know that's that's part of it i'm
able to recognize
and translate just like that oh that's
so good
recognize and translate i love that yeah
for others
i do it for others exactly exactly
it helps me also to fulfill the other
part of it which
is like keeping things on track
keeping things relevant not allowing
stuff to go off
the rails i keep things very relevant
for people
all the time you know i mean a glorified
accountability partner i guess ooh
[Laughter]
now i also know deeper why
mesh and sharok we're also mentioning
like like co-creating with andrea is
really important like look at this
recognize and translate so that's
another feature that i'm really
familiar with so it's beautiful that
you're beginning to unpack this because
in a sense once you sort of get into
these
as bentino talks about this like these
bubble realities that
click and right what's happening is
when you undergo this process of
clicking in
for this conversation this interaction
that's happening
the more that you can register recognize
the other person and translate to them
both what their unique essence is they
feel like you care about them they feel
like you're genuinely interested in
asking them questions
and listening to them speak about what
unique firework of the infinite they are
what part of their spiritual awakening
process they're in
and within like a couple of minutes you
can just build this really strong
rapport with somebody
because you know how to do it after
going through hundreds of thousands of
these examples
and it is happening i do care i think
that's why i
i can access it too is because i do care
like
it you said it makes you feel like
i care i do you know so that's part of i
think that's part of what makes it
precise
that's part of what gives it precision
yes and focus
because it's fueled by
yes that that love love that's what it's
fueled
exactly and you know it used to be quite
a
a detriment in my life because that was
always my thing is i could recognize
everything i recognize everything you
know not just the stuff
people want me to recognize and so it
used to be a detriment
and i have long since learned how to
use it for not only my benefit but the
benefit of
the other at the same time
and that's just i suppose practice
maturity
discipline purification yes
yes a
really good simple example for people
is when you kind of click into these
bubble realities
can you keep at the top of your
awareness
the top of your attention can you keep
whether you're coming from a place of
wanting to
extract something from the other person
to fulfill one of your
needs or lack beliefs or wanting to be
seen or trying to extract peace and
happiness
from them in some way or when you
lock in are you coming from a place at
the top of your awareness top of your
attention
to serve truly like you said coming from
a place of love pure love after
purifying purifying purifying
it was we were in conversation together
when you
mentioned you said locked in
right that's right and so you get this
one intelligence to one infinite creator
you get that locked
in and once you get that really situated
it's much easier when you get into these
conversations
to be coming from a place of not needing
anything
and just serving hold the holding space
mechanism as well as serving exactly the
needs of what the other person is going
through to unblock to access freedom
that they already are yeah
and and and you can i mean the whole
idea is to get it locked
in almost unconsciously
right so that every time i open my mouth
because i open my mouth a lot so
every time i'm gonna open my mouth then
i need to not have to think
twice about where i'm coming from so
that's been a heavy
and consistent practice and unpacking
and inquiry for me
over and over again especially after
interactions for a long long time in my
life to be able to be in this place
where
i don't really think twice about it it's
quite rare that
you know i'm not giving to the situation
the other thing too i would find myself
in the past doing is
um you know how you said fulfilling
a need for me which i mean i guess it is
a similar
thing but fulfilling a need for someone
else too
like that you know and then you would
think well no no i'm
fulfilling a need for them you know and
so it ends up being the same thing
because of course
there's only one of us anyway so
yes and then once you realize that
okay it's done it's an all or nothing
thing i mean this whole journey is all
or nothing
it can't be parched over here over here
all
you know there's only one and
but over here i know better than god
yeah compartmentalizing so we chop
ourselves up into these little tiny
pieces and we decide like
well this i need to make sure i take
care of this
like god can't take care of i can't
leave that to god
are you freaking kidding me this over
here i have to you know and this
but over here okay i can and what we
start to realize is that that's
like that's not under that's divided
you know and really we want to come from
that
undivided wholeness which means
everything is the same thing
and also everything has to be imbued
like i
love what richard said in the costa rica
retreat about the infinite concern and
the finite concerns
and how we need to bring the infinite
concern
down to imbue the finite concerns so
that we can remember
that now they're not finite anymore
because they're fueled by the truth and
the love and the light and the awareness
so it turns them into sacred so
everything's sacred
or nothing sacred
gosh that's so good there's no dividing
of this area will be
the separate self trying to extract
peace and happiness out of reality
but this area over here okay i'll let
this area maybe
like with kids this one's sometimes a
little bit more like
oh i had this profound as a parent i
birthed the child into the world
and now because of that i've opened up
my heart chakra a little bit i'm less
selfish
so now i'm willing to like give more to
serve
this child and so now you've brought
some sort of
infinite concern to only one member of
your family you know type thing
and like but anybody outside of the
family no no no no they're still solar
plexus
the ego is still strong there but
the heart only opened up for your
offspring it's so fascinating
how like that kind of relationship it
works for relationships too
and you know having that one significant
other
then that becomes the most important
relationship in your
life and everything else every other
relationship is less important you know
but when you actually bring it in
in that truth there's no difference
between any relationship you have with
anyone
anywhere ever they're all the same
they're all the same they may have
slightly different
um forms i suppose
taste um maybe even tastes cool
tastes cool and even even then that gets
transcended but it's cool to stay at the
taste
stage it's it's cute for sure to
switch between the lenses of perception
for that
as you would like am i gonna relate to
somebody different than i relate to this
person or that like i mean that's just
not
i'm not in integrity
when i do that i'm not in it where's my
integrity
you know how i show up depends on who i
decide i'm going to be not
who anybody else is or isn't
and that's when we say the locked in
then you're always perpetually showing
up from the place of
intelligent infinity at play with itself
and therefore
serving the creation awakening truly
shepherding it in a non-attached way
so i don't need to do this for
me to feel better because i'm the agent
that is
serving the creation awakening to be
seen as that there's all these little
tricky nuances you mentioned this and i
thought this
i thought this was really interesting
it's that
you don't need to think twice about when
you where you're coming from
i feel like this is a very advanced
level of spiritual awakening and i feel
like it could be useful for us to unpack
this
on the show so i would say that
the the moment when you
realize that you've been coming from a
place
of separation perpetually is like the
first profound like
wow like i get that i've been coming
from that place perpetually and then
you sort of begin to sort of see over
and over again
like okay so there's these streams of
where i can come
from god from intelligent infinity
verses come
from my separate contracted person
condition identity
and then you over time you you know you
pick
more and more towards this until it
locks in
and as it locks in then these
conditioning still occasionally kind of
bubble up but you're in a much more
gnostic place and so yeah you can see
them
coming you can see them coming at that
point but you know
the first realization that you're
talking about the first one where you
realize
you're in a thief and you have been your
entire [ __ ] life
that all you ever do is pretend
in order to get people to like you or
accept you or believe you
in order to make your space when you
realize that like when you actually
realize that in your life
it's devastating it's devastating it's
so devastating
devastating okay and i mean and it's and
it's okay
i feel like it's okay if it's
devastating allow it to annihilate you
because as gangaji would say
allow your feelings to annihilate you
and you will find that which cannot be
annihilated
and so then you have to recover
like then it takes some time to recover
from that for many
there's grief that comes along with that
you know forgiveness um
you know i really think that that's one
of the first stages of
the know yourself accept yourself become
the creator i think that's one of the
first stages of knowing yourself
is when you realize oh my god i'm
a fraud and i've been a fraud my whole
life
yeah so then then we go from there
and if people stick to it if people can
recover can indeed recover from that
well then there's only one
directionality to go now and it's
more awareness in order to like
vigilantly practice
and then every interaction is on the
chopping block
it's like why did i say that how come
this why this why that
until you get really used to seeing
your lack in action your fraudulence and
action
and then it becomes identifiable very
quickly
you know and then you even get to a
point where i did anyway
where i notice it
mid interaction
and even
admit it or declare it mid interaction
with whomever i'm speaking with
and then turn it around at the same time
and that's a trip like transparently
in front of people [ __ ] look what i just
did
and you sort of share with them this is
what's happening for me right now
and i need to just take a moment to like
tell the truth about this and then i
want to flip the script
and come from a better place damn that's
so high level i love that
[ __ ] yeah it's so just courageous
and brave i love that yep
that's a very high level of awakening
again is
just when you have total
freedom with speaking the
truth as it's going to hurt you to admit
like it hurts you it's like a confession
it is it is
it's like a confession and every
relationship becomes a confessional
yeah yeah you know wow that's so
profound
but i feel like it helps it helped me
along in such a faster way
than if i would have kept that process
locked inside of me
you know and beating my head against the
wall plus i've
since learned as well from many people
that i did that process with for myself
who graciously held space for me in
those moments
how much they learned from that for
themselves
you know so i feel like in that moment i
could automatically turn into service to
others
just by sharing my process yeah that's
so cool
you know and that's how come i think
this whole idea of transparency when
we're in a group like right or wrong
doesn't matter
are you being real even if it sucks just
be real
yeah just be real yeah it doesn't matter
because that can
once we see it we can change it that's
so perfect yeah exactly
perfect
i love how simple the just be real is
it's just so
directly concise and punctual
and it kind of gives either if you're
asking yourself just be real about it or
if you're asking somebody else in the
scenario
just be real about it it gives the
exact short concise burst permission
slip
to enable the okay was that
the truth or was that an untruth and
then
was that coming from the contracted
person identity or is it coming from god
and you get to literally have the moment
the permissions up it's such a quick
permission slip
to just do that check moment until you
get it
where you don't need to have to just be
real
yeah well and i and
you know within um i have a partner of
10 years
and uh you know we do our best to to
have as conscious
of a relationship as we can and and just
be real
you know how that translates sometimes
for us is
i'm scared and so
i'm i'm not going to do that thing or
i'm not going to go in that place or i'm
unable to go
like so it's just as simple as being
real enough to own the fact that you're
scared shitless and you're not ready to
go there whatever there wherever there
is
you know instead of posturing and
pushing and forcing and becoming that
opposite thing
you know in your ego that is just
shows everybody any way that you're
scared but instead of compensating
using compensated behavior and
showing everyone you're scared anyway
because who the hell can't see through
that [ __ ]
instead it's like just be real i'm
scared
not so easy yeah but even from partner
to partner
like in a relationship to be able to say
that
then it's easy for me to say okay cool
you got this like i i
trust that you're gonna figure it out
because you know that you're scared so
you know what to do
and cool
i can i can go do me
yeah so it's a big thing
and and what about a group setting same
thing like how many people
in a group setting you know all of a
sudden
the topic turns into something and it
rubs up against you
and instead of just saying whoa that's
freaking me out like that's
touching everything inside of me that's
making me angry or that's making me
scared no
what do we do instead it's like well
i think this or i think that you know we
try to legitimize the fear
by pushing it into some sort of like
makeshift idea instead of just
admitting the truth the thing is you can
go so much farther when you do
when you don't you have to go through
all that so that's oftentimes
where i come in to keep things on track
is in moments like that
where i'm just like okay clearly
you know you're scared so where do we
have to go with this
do you need help right now can you talk
to somebody in a minute
can we continue with what we're doing
here or
you know
and it's maybe it's not easy to hear but
yeah this is some ultimate space holding
stuff
this is really ultimate space holding i
love it we should we should start a show
ultimate space holders
which is i guess in a sense what what
nls
is kind of in a little bit um ultimate
purification yeah yeah
it's just it's beautiful it is and it's
like how do you
how do you actually create anything
or get anything done i mean quote
unquote
or stay on topic
when you can't be honest
right because then you have to veer off
into all these directions and all those
directions have nothing to do with
anything except
whoever's speaking their lack
um that's it or otherwise we'd be on
point with
what we're talking and it's not bad it's
not a bad thing
at all it's inevitable i mean that's
part
that's what it's really about that's
what everything's really about
you know it's not about our job or our
relationship or
that's not the thing that's just the
thing to get us to pay attention to the
thing
but it in and of itself is not the thing
we're not doing it for the relationship
or for the job or for the money
you know those are just the catalysts
that help us to pay attention to the
actual
thing but everything's everything
from the moment you open your eyes you
are bombarded with catalysts
period yes yes so
if that's the case then it's just like
way better to just
surrender
every time because then you have a
chance
if you don't you got no chance
you're just going to be running and
bumping and running forever
yeah i love the visualization
of
seeing catalysts
everywhere in a massive
webbed play
that the creation is and that
if you begin seeing like the complexity
of like in buddhism called
this dependent origination there's all
of these insane causal webs of
thousands of things that happen for you
to just get
your blueberries you know there's
all of the at all these levels or you
know even your little
like you described a moment ago you
you're speaking
but speaking from where is this speaking
from a place of lack so that the other
person can say
oh yeah yeah validate you
or is this right or is it coming from uh
like a place of like just a child like
fire working
expressive is it coming because you
already know it's all love
uh is it coming from the place of
potentially exploring holding space
for unblocking for for others to enable
more
freedom of the life to wake up to itself
so that's a core i would say distinction
is both seeing the catalysts everywhere
because then you gain that hyper subtle
perception
to see that and then it feedbacks on
itself
and and then the other one is that we
kind of been talking about this but it's
just
boils down to in our the title of the
episode that we've been
using is getting it right what what is
that
is that as simple as we've been talking
about
is getting you being intelligent
infinity everything being intelligent
infinity
and not when you don't get it
it's when you come from this place of
lack from separate contracted
identity yeah exactly
exactly and and getting it can be like a
really tiny little
shift that creates a realization in the
moment small
somebody can get it a small little tiny
realization
that helps them to understand
something about who they are
or a big huge one but either way it
doesn't matter because
when i work with people and they have
this just this
tiny shift that enables them to
get something about who they are even a
glimpse
it freaking blows up their life
it changes them in so many ways
you know because here's the thing when
you don't get it
you don't know that you're not getting
it
that's the heart that's what's so
difficult you want to know i'm going to
tell you the story about this calling
when i was five years old and
i was having a it was my birthday
and i blew out the candles on my cake it
was just my family
my mother my father me uh
and my two sisters my brother wasn't
even born yet
and i finished blowing out my candles
and my father said
what do you want to be when you grow up
yeah and i said oh i was so excited
because i knew exactly what to say and i
said
oh daddy i don't want to be anything i
just want to help turn the world
right side up that's what i said to him
and he backhanded me across the face
hard and said don't ever say that again
and in that moment do you know what
occurred to me at five years old with
two things
oh my god he doesn't get it
in that moment i was like i get it he
doesn't get it
and the second thing that occurred to me
in that moment was
this isn't going to be as easy as i
thought it would be
and that so so i've known that
since then and i was
forcefully not allowed to pursue it
you see for most of my upbringing
and especially like when we were talking
earlier about
culture and growing up in an italian
family and
you know so that always factored in big
for me because i had to obey
which means i could never ever make my
own decisions or do
what it was that i felt was important to
do
so it took it took a long time and now i
obviously look back and i realized of
course that was all
needed i chose that the pressure
because i chose to
and transform it yes even just to show
that it can be
that it has really no
it never went away who i was never went
away like you know how ben
says once you realize it you can't
unrealize it
so i knew it from five it never went
away
i was just biding my time abiding my
time
i mean of course by the time i left my
family i was
riddled with baggage
lots of it you know but
simultaneously that realization was
there as well
so that's what fueled me i was like i
got a lot of work to do now
i gotta begin the work of disabusing
myself of all of these
defense mechanisms that at one time had
purpose
and now no longer serve me at all if i
want to do what i said i'm gonna do
so what a profound
that's the story it that i'm talking
about wow
and i i encounter people all the time
who have that same mentality as my
father
and i and i get it i get it
you know it doesn't bother me anymore it
used to bother me a lot it doesn't
bother me anymore
now i realize that all they want to do
is get it
yeah because it's the same
yeah so how can i serve that and of
course i know exactly how
i grew up with the king of that
my father
wow yeah holy [ __ ] yeah
that was that was a huge
story from such a young age
we usually don't have such yeah pivotal
highly remembered stories at young ages
like that
and it was really interesting also how
you said that you don't want to be
anything but that you want to flip the
world right side up
always in my head that was always a
narrative in my head for sure
that as a child i always perceived the
world was
upside down but that
you could turn it right side up you
could
like upside down and backwards kind of
yeah that's been a
common one of the sort of spiritual
wisdom
as well yeah turn everything like
outside
in um as well another way yeah
but i really like that in a sense it's
like there's an attractor and it's
maya it's the illusion and it's it's all
the way out here at the farthest pole
and then there's this other pole which
is the absolute in its gps call back and
you have these two poles at play and
like this is the
whole journey and the whole experience
of intelligent infinity playing with
itself happens
and even that's a [ __ ] story because
it's all just non-dual
and yeah but it's but it's funny to sort
of like
architect out a map that seemingly makes
sense
and that's totally what you're
sharing it's like you you know
even from such a young age that there's
why is it this way
like is this not supposed to be a plate
a playland
because because
it's both very much so
you know heaven on earth but it's also
disaster on earth simultaneously
and we all know that that's caused by
one thing
this contracted identity of separation
and and that that's the thing that you
then
went after but you couldn't go after
because
you were held back by this style of
familial yeah
vibe which is so common in cultures is
like
i'm gonna have a kid and then i'm gonna
control the [ __ ] out of that kid
and then it's like bruh like
give a little bit of infinity some of
it's will brah like
you're just you're just choking the will
brah like
yeah and uh
and then it pressure cooked it pressure
cooked you
because then you you know you sprung out
because who knows you could have went
for like
whatever the couple of like five year
increments
in the process of just sort of tasting
of what you were set out to do and just
kind of you know
maybe went up a couple steps in the
process but because you were pressure
cooked so much like a freaking wind-up
toy then like as soon as you broke out
of that
like it all unwound and you rocked it up
like so many of these
like and now you're doing everything
you're doing today at this much more
sort of larger macro level view
of what is possible yeah that's what it
felt like
i mean yeah i mean the next
greatest space for me happened
maybe 10 years after
i had you know i i stayed
where my my father lived where my family
lived for quite some
time well into my 30s and the end of my
30s
and at one point i i finally decided to
leave i said this is it i'm leaving i
had a child
i was a single mother and i took that
child and said we're going to move east
we're going to go move to where my
sister is
and i'm going to finally live my life
on my own terms so that's where that
comes from
and my father said to me when i told him
he said to me
something that he would say to me that
he's been saying to me my whole life
every time i wanted to do something that
he didn't
agree with he would say if you do that
you are no longer my daughter you're no
longer a part of this family you will no
longer be welcome in this house and i
will never speak to you again
that's he used to say that to me
ongoingly at least once a week
and i'm not joking so at that time
when i told him that
i called his bluff i said well
if that's what's going to happen then
that's what's going to happen
see you later and i left and he didn't
talk to me for seven years
and i and i wasn't considered part of
that family for seven years
but you know what's crazy is in the
funniest
most unconscious way that he didn't
realize
he set me free
he set me free in such a wonderful
amazing way
and i was able to full speed ahead go
ahead and do my thing without ever again
having to look over my shoulder carte
blanche is what he gave me
and i'm grateful to him for this day to
this day i'm grateful to him for that
even though he doesn't know about that
so from that point it was about 10 years
later
that i had another
really profound understanding and
realization
as i worked through all of my
conditioning and especially my cultural
baggage and all of that
and it was that none of that ever
happened
none of it ever happened to me none of
it
i am completely unscathed by
all of it and that realization
enabled me to clean up
all the last little snail trails of
baggage
that i was hanging on to wow
that's what did it that was the momentum
with that realization that like
this is none of this is true you are
totally unaffected by all of it it never
happened and then it was just like
done
you know all of it was gone
and now i don't identify
the way that i move in the world against
my family of origin
anymore it's done it's finished it did
its job
doesn't mean i don't slip
at all doesn't mean that of course i do
but that's mine
not my family that's mine
i'll be the judge of that i'll be the
fixer or
changer or transformer of that nothing
and no one can get in the way of what i
decide
to do with that
and it's freeing
very freeing
damn pops he really created that
pressure cooker
those are those are really big ultimatum
points
like yeah those are huge ones and then
like just that like the courage that's
needed to
to get past those to find these massive
gifts and treasures on the other side
and i really love how you go you explain
going through the process
of deconditioning the separate
self-identity
and then realizing that it never
happened to you
and that's like the second sort of
profound realization that then
enables the the energy of the entity to
sort of
relax and surrender at an even more
unprecedented level
and sort of lock in as we've been saying
the getting it of the one intelligence
like this
whole universal odyssey that we
designed that was so beautiful that i
went on as
intelligent infinity also never happened
yeah and that's when you get this
nothingness this infinitude and this
beautiful andrea
that you get all at the same time
and you can navigate through these
lenses
as you will because here you are telling
a story about your little
you know five-year-old cake uh
and blowing up the candles like you
can't flip the world right side up
you know like that story one could
easily
sort of just be like oh nothing happened
and one could
easily be like i'm just empty full uh
but instead it's like
it's like the beauty of this beauty of
being like
i can put on the andrea lens and tell
you this beautiful story that will also
help
share for other people in their journeys
what could be very useful and valid as
well
and helpful so i see just see a lot of
young people
in that same place especially now like i
know i know like it wouldn't have
it wasn't gonna go any other way for me
because the
the strength of conviction i was so much
in my strength of conviction
at five there was just no other
thing that was it and nothing could
change
my mind it wasn't even like it was my
mind
i didn't feel that way so
that was never going to go away and i
feel like
maybe that wasn't so and maybe that
wasn't as
common at that time when i was young
you know for many children
to feel that way at five or have that
conviction at five years old
but more and more that's the case
more and more that's the case i see it
because we all are born in a different
jumping off place
generation after generation after
generation so
i can see so many kids now
that age or even just a little tiny bit
older
and they too know they too have that
conviction
but they're not allowed to
and it's like it always struck me even
at five years old as a weird thing like
if i'm not allowed to have this
conviction
then how do i have it um
yeah it was such a weird thing when i
was younger
yeah yeah yeah it's like you're telling
me i'm not allowed
that doesn't it's not having any effect
yeah it's not effectively changing
anything about the conviction
wow it's so interesting how the we you
we
we were talking about earlier we were
talking about like catalysts
like just swimming in this ocean of
catalyst but it can also
be viewed simultaneously as this
programming between entities of
intelligent infinity
and they're just so interesting you got
this like older
software running that's like it's like
on
it's totally unblocked from you know
solar plexus to
heart let's say and that you have like
this kid
that's like in many ways we can say that
kids have
super unblocked chakras
and kids are just like they're swimming
in infinite possibility
and like a kid is wanting to
we've actually had um
we had maya romitas on the show and
maya is nine years old oh see
yeah and she spent a good chunk of the
show
explaining to us how
annoying it was when she
was trying to color a
animal a way that it's not normally
colored in the world and then
and the teacher is just like you can't
do that it's stupid
and so this is the infinite possibility
trying to express itself
and then this sort of like older
unblocked
yeah the older blocked
entity that's running software that does
not enable the other
less blocked entity to pursue its
infinite possibility
yeah that's right yeah yeah it's pretty
common it's pretty common
it's cute it's cute when it's really
brought to the child level as well
because it's also really relatable
because adults have also went through
similar processes it doesn't even
sometimes it doesn't matter if it was at
five or if it was that
people feel like it happened when they
were a teenager or when it happened when
they're an adult in the workplace
just like like i'm
i'm swimming in this beautiful infinite
possibility
and like
it's kind of funny because as a kid when
you're kind of told
that you're infinite possibility
is dumb and it doesn't work
that oh yeah when you're when you're an
adult
because we've sort of went through this
process as well you're
we're submitting really great ideas for
the projects that we're working on and
all this type of stuff
and we learn how to also like not be
attached to it which is kind of
interesting
like we'll give it up so easily yeah
it's so interesting yeah
yeah yeah no for sure
it's crazy oh my gosh it's so crazy
but all part and parcel
gosh that's so cool your
your journey actually rings
so true to your current
entity state of being totally so
true to it like the story
matches so well to what you represent
energetically now
like wow and you describe it so
perfectly as this like
pressure cooker that then caused this
super explosive freedom firework
oh big time and i've never felt um
like i've always felt that way now like
since that happened
it's like i'm i'm endlessly free and
endlessly
transformative and liberated and
like there's no excuse there's no um
blockage there's no like just go
that's it like i don't have the moment i
don't have time
i don't have um the inclination to
complain or to um be bothered
or to yeah i mean and any emotion is
very short-lived
because i do think it's important to
feel your emotions
that's it but they're not for anything
else
and so when you start using them for
other things then you start
becoming a victim and living from that
place
but if you just feel them they'll most
likely change within i don't know
90 seconds if that
and then keep going keep going i'm not a
robot
by any means but at the same time
i'm not going to be following shiny
objects around either
no way i am my shiny object
oh [ __ ] i love that one it's a good one
i am my shiny object i am
that's who i follow that infinity inside
yeah and i know the difference we all do
we all know the difference
[ __ ] if you tell me you don't know
the difference
between coming from one place or another
you know what it feels like to be
infinitely free
and everyone knows but not everybody
wants to
do the work or make the decisions
that you need to in order to have that
constantly consistently but it is
available
to everybody all the time and everybody
i think
everybody innately knows what that feels
like
i don't think it's learned at all i
think it's inherent
innate
more innate than like the conditionals
totally totally
yeah the whole
odyssey
is perfectly designed to have
that feedback mechanism that you're
talking about where people
know the difference now if we're running
the scripts
that make us completely
automatic it's really difficult to get
the entry into becoming aware of what is
being discussed
now there's there's still no but you
know you know
because like you said as a kid
especially there was more of what was
true
in terms of especially that like freedom
and just joy and
peace and play and all that type of
stuff and then all of a sudden there's
this cage
in this box and all of this like
and and then it's like what is this and
then you know there's a difference
between those and you know that
they're you know the process of melting
this cageless cage
is you know ramana maharshi it's either
zero steps to freedom or endless steps
to freedom
and you know sometimes you
it's a choice to say that it's gonna be
zero steps to freedom and then to find
yourself a really
[ __ ] good guru a really good
truth channel that then helps just the
unblocking within yourself because
you're the one that's doing all of the
unblocking
of melting that cageless cage and then
going right back to that state of
of pure freedom but there there's got to
be this as close as possible to the
ineffable
it's true it's ineffable but as close as
possible as you can get
use that use those symbols
those maps those interpretations to
[ __ ]
abide as the perfect freedom that it
already all is
yeah it's in us to do yes
we're sure yes it's why we're here
so and we all know the difference and
it's all going in that direction and
only the time it takes for you to get on
board
is your choice that's it
perfect perfect it's a cosmological
mechanism
so you may as well decide to be reality
awakening to itself
earlier rather than pursuing the shiny
objects outside of yourself
yeah you might as well participate
excellent you know excellent
did you may i be sensing that you feel
like
you you do you need to go to another
meeting or
do you have oh god no no no no i just
have to shift
yeah i don't have a tripod or anything
and i'm kind of holding
my phone because i don't have a computer
so
but i don't have anything else scheduled
this is it baby
okay cool cool we'll probably ride for
yeah however yeah no worries
yeah cool we can take our time i'm not
in a rush
cool because we've been unpacking some
beautiful things and you could get a
little
um either yeah pop socket or a little
um like gorilla just to put the phone
up against something or whatnot just to
make it easier i know actually i have
one but i didn't bring it with me
okay yeah i do have a tripod like it
could have been set up right here by the
bed and i could have
been yeah yeah cool cool i'll learn i'll
learn
even a computer i'm gonna have to break
down and buy one i think like i've
written
almost my entire book on my phone
imagine
yeah this just it feels more convenient
for me in a lot of ways
i don't know how else to yeah just that
people just think i'm crazy
what what do you do and i don't type
either
yeah voice to text it yeah yeah i could
do that too but
anyway for other reasons it wasn't about
the book that i would get the computer
but it's more for other reasons like all
these zoom calls now
and all that you know maybe it would
come in handy
so we'll see i love the idea of just
being able to
like walk right out to that beach in
bali
that you're at with your phone and write
the book
yeah because it's that much easier than
lugging a laptop yeah
yeah yeah and it's just i don't know
i like having it because i can do it
anywhere
i have to be prepared i just have to
have my phone with me and yeah
there it is so that's a good thing
yeah and coming to bali living in bali
moving to bali then that was the
beginning of another whole body of work
you know of really extricating myself
from
the world as i knew it
you know and coming to live
here which gave me an in-between
space to live in because i'm not part of
this world or this culture
and i'm too far away from the one i left
and so i have this really
privileged place in between where
there's a lot of freedom
for me to take advantage of all the
beauty
and energetics of this island
without having to pay for it
you know like sell a part of your soul
for it so that's a really wonderful
position to be in and the energy's here
as like with every island
are very concise
you know the purer you are the more
those energies kind of fuel you
help you uplift you purify you
you know and the more you are
living in your ego and your untruth
coming from that place the more you're a
liar a cheater and a stealer
the more it aids you in
your demise it just makes things worse
so that's a really crazy and and for me
it's very very i love it that's my
favorite thing about being here is i
feel
very upheld by those energies completely
and in bali the veil between the light
and the dark is very thin
it's all about the dark spirits and the
demons
and the you know but also about the
light that's very black and white
so it's a very cool existence
in that way especially when you're not
invested in the religious aspect of it
which of course i'm not
i mean the whole religious thing is
another another story
that they're all living which is great
and there's some beauty in it
and i'm sure it also adds to because
there's a lot of
offerings and a lot of ceremonies and
i'm sure all of that energy
adds to you know a greater
energy that exists here but at the same
time it's not really about the religion
so i'm happy that i'm not experiencing
it from within that religion
but i get to experience it from my
vantage point
so i really
i love being here and i wouldn't want to
be
anywhere else right now and that's not
to say i travel around
for sure and i'm about to do a bunch of
traveling right now
so indonesia i'm going to travel
indonesia which is a good thing
since i haven't done that yet and i've
been on this island for how long
so yeah so we're gonna we're gonna
travel around and
spend no more than three months in each
place for at least a year
oh okay so it's cool because this
relocation vibration especially to a
place like
bali where you can leverage
the unleashing of the fullest creative
capacities
with not
draining too big of a hole in the wallet
is excellent because the entire
vibe of ocean and nature
energy is just further fueling
what is unleashing creatively
because a lot of the time you won't see
specific nuanced aspects to
life that when you're locked in a
bedroom
it just has an example but anyway
there's that component and then there's
the component of
like you mentioned the difference
between when you see things completely
non-dually versus when you still see
things dualistically
and like kind of seeing that vantage
point this is so interesting because
you can go one level up to see it but
the
ones here can't yet see it um
and then because i was also there and i
love
being at the level of it so much better
and so
you're
you feel like
the next year you're gonna go
you're gonna go every
three months to a new place
near that area so indonesia might be
less
but no more than three months like if
there's a place we want to
you know rent the place and stay for a
bit we have three months
that's it are you going with your sister
i'm gonna go with my partner
with your partner okay cool yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so we may you know like i think we're
gonna start in java
and we wanna there's a whole bunch like
java is huge
there's 17 000 islands
that make up bali yeah that's so crazy
so there's a lot of places to go see you
know
so we'll start there see where that
brings us and then we're going to travel
across front and go to zumba and zumbawa
and who knows there's just so many i
mean we won't do it all in a year and i
don't even know where that year will
end us up maybe we'll just keep going
the thing that's happening for both of
us right now
simultaneously funnily enough is that
we're not interested in location anymore
yeah i'm not interested in being in one
place anymore i've had enough of it i
don't want to keep a house
and i don't want to it doesn't give me
anything that i want it used to it
doesn't anymore
so i need to be free to move around i
want to go wherever i want to go
whenever i want to go there i would like
there's so many places
to stay here that you can stay in i
i don't care it's fine but i no longer
want to be
in one place like have a home
i'm done with having a home right now
you know that may change again but for
right now it doesn't make any sense to
me to have a home
i mean i i feel like my home is just
with me wherever i am
so it doesn't matter right
yeah home is the sh
i am my shiny object yeah yeah exactly
so now i just want to yeah
travel around continue doing what i'm
doing
continue writing continue you know this
group right now has been
my life i've started uh started with
nlm in january and
it was exactly what i was looking for
are you andrea are you in no limits
mentorship
yeah and have you been in it since
january
since january since it started yeah okay
cool so
just for those that are listening that
don't know no limits mentorship
is where people like andrea about 22 or
so people
are in it something get
get one-on-one get to ask
one on one questions to bentino as a
group
as a group they get to ask questions to
bentino and then bentino
responds with these questions and then
they do zoom calls
and what are the other nlm perks
well i mean just being in a closed um
chat group like that is has many
advantages at what as well in terms of
just each other and how we're reflecting
to each other
and shepherding each other what we're
co-creating and creating together
um getting to know one another
getting to know how we all
work and also purification on
times 10. yes yes like i mean it can
also be none of that
it depends you know on how much you're
going to immerse yourself
in there how transparent you're going to
allow yourself
to be how much you're going to share you
know obviously the more that you
participate the more you're going to get
out of it
so putting yourself on the line is a big
part of it
but yeah i mean really purifying our
desires in that group
is a big big part of it
interesting that the sort of top-down
purification
comes from bentino and the team that
have already been undergoing this
process for so long
and then there's also this sort of
bottom-up purification that's happening
in terms of you guys together yeah which
is super
interesting and i also have a similar
somewhat experience with
nls where it's both happening top down
and bottom up
and then all the great friendships and
stuff that are
yeah becoming and i love the way it's
merging now
like this is the ultimate for me is the
way that it's merging in that way
you know so i love it because it's all
yeah people are people they all inspire
me all the time
in so many ways it's insane
yep that's another core insight by the
way it looks
like you're something's blocking a part
of the camera
oh that's my thigh oh i thought that was
like your leg or something cool yeah
yeah because i'm holding it in between
my knees
yeah that's my tripod yeah it's my
tripod right now
yeah i saw both your hands appear in the
shot and i was like
okay there's something happening that
i'm not uh
so yeah i'm really enjoying i'm enjoying
it a lot
it's um
it's just furthering
you know what what i've been already
working on and what it was
and also in terms of the team aspect too
that's been very exciting because
that's in fact why i applied
because i knew i just had a feeling
that like i mean what it's just going to
go on ad nauseam month after month
no it's heading somewhere it's heading
somewhere
the people in this group something's
gonna we're gonna do something we're
gonna be part of something and we're
gonna and that's all i want
it's like it's the turning the world
right side up again yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's so cool
yeah i i will not rest and you know my
five-year-old
so yeah yeah it's cool that you had
you knew that that there was that
evolutionary blossoming that was going
to unfold and that
there was that that there was that
purification aspect to it plus
the service at a larger level that's
unfolding
and you know how i knew you know how i
knew truly is because
i'm going to be part of it
that's how i knew if i'm going to be
part of it oh well then i know
where it's headed
[Laughter]
yeah that's it that's it you know that's
it
for sure for sure i know exactly where
it's headed if i'm gonna be part of it
and i feel that way in many situations
you know in
unknown situations that are ahead of me
uh
what if you don't like it what if it's
this what if it's that what if it's the
other
for me it's always i'll be there so
it'll be great
i'll be there so
what do what do i have to be afraid of
you know
that's always been my thing like well
i'll be there
so yeah no worries
and i feel the same way about that
obviously as long as i'm there
i can't lose
so yeah and that's another one of my
puzzle pieces is i'm like
freakishly optimistic all the time
all the time
it's like a i don't know maybe it's a
blueprint
thing or i don't know
but i'm i'm unable to be negative
really i love that
well it also speaks to a lot of
eradicating the roots of suffering
yeah yeah no doubt no doubt
no doubt for sure oh
my god yeah suffering no thank you
yeah for sure
like either one's okay really
but it's a choice that's the only thing
sometimes i choose it but there's a
reason
but mostly it doesn't have to accompany
me
mostly not
yeah i can so sense this just
explosiveness
post super
contracted cage energetic
freedom radical optimism
i'm gonna be there like i'm gonna flip
the world
right side up yeah
yeah with with with everybody else who
wants to do the same
right yeah it's by no means a one-woman
job yeah
you know radical unattachment
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then like
bentino says
when you're so detached it's important
then to
be careful not to be attached to that
attached to radical attachment
because it's easy it's easy for me to be
detached
and so it's also easy to use that as a
way
ouch yeah yeah
so be being careful on that front
the balance yeah yeah
but it's like but you have to go all the
way to the pole
if you don't go all the way to the pole
you'll still have some stinky little
attachments yeah yeah yeah but also so
that you know
you can as well because going all the
way to the pole
could be purposeful if as long as it's
coming from the right place
it can be purposeful right so even in
learning how to become detached
i realize that it's like okay well why
am i choosing this
over that and i know okay well no you're
you're detached from the outcome it's
not about that it's not nobody then i
realize
oh it's because i'm detached
that i need to do that thing
because for the first time it's not
coming from some kind of greed or need
or
whatever so you got to do it now now's
the time to do that thing
because now it's going to have an actual
impact because you don't really care
so it's about those finding those
things out where the whole purpose of
attachment is
freedom or detachment it's freedom
so that you can walk into anything as
long as you're coming from the right
place
and serve whatever
that service requires you can do it
because you're detached
but you're not serving yourself
so that's kind of cool too because it's
like almost like
oh okay i gotta oh i can yeah
give myself permission to do that thing
there which normally i would think
is nasty but it's like yeah but you're
not doing it to be nasty
you know so everything like it doesn't
matter what it is
it only matters why doesn't matter what
and what one man's treasure is another
man's trash
so what doesn't matter and there's only
so much under the sun
but the why why you're doing it why you
said it
why you chose it why you're coming from
there
that's all that matters
that's what i think creates the
power or the fuel or the flavor of the
thing
is the why
it's great
yeah and sometimes
with clients that i work with
that's an exercise every time you make a
choice ask yourself why
every single time every time they're
like yeah well i'm going to be doing
that all day i'm like yeah that's the
point
all day every day every time you're
cognizant of a choice
ask yourself why
it's great exercise get really
sensitive at where you're coming from
guess and also get really sensitive at
how often you choose
yeah become aware yeah
you know that you're choosing in every
second
and you're either king kong you know
or walking through but you know i'm
gonna put my foot here and i'm gonna put
my well i gotta walk and it's like yeah
okay
there goes a whole building of people
there goes a hole
you know yeah being sensitive
being aware oh
wow yeah
i think it gets easier i think it gets
more automatic like we said
it totally gets more automatic but
there's uh
it's so funny sometimes there will be
this
like beautiful just
flowing of the free perfection
and then there will also be this like
the free perfection noticing
that like well
like i'm pretty sure there's still some
[ __ ] here
and then like that's also like the
process of
uh knowing that there's still some
fraudulent stuff
and that the flow will naturally show
that fraudulent stuff
um yeah and it's just so funny because
like this is like this is like the last
thing
like the last thing is to sort of like
just disappear into the ordinary
like stop seeking to be seen
like just disappear into life itself
like undergo this process of
no self just disappear into life itself
like be cool with being nobody everybody
and somebody but without
any attachment to being seen by the rest
of life
just be life itself rather than being a
separate person trying to extract peace
and happiness and all this other stuff
from
life like i just love that like
adiashanti style
die into the ordinary just die into the
ordinary
and that just makes me feel so
much more at ease and relaxed and
surrendered and at peace
when i can sort of look at that
intellectually
and then begin embodying it more
experientially and just feeling the slow
realization of it really become more and
more
anchored in
be known only to yourself
you're you're known only to yourself
well to be known only to yourself
it's me who needs to know only me
only me hmm
yeah you're the somebody
chunk of life that wants
the seeking impulses to become
transparent to your nature
that's right to know to know myself
sorry i had to plug in
know your mind know your mind and
and when we are practicing knowing our
mind
it also happens to be that our mind is
ourselves
at that time it is we identify our minds
with ourselves and our
right so to really be known
by yourself actually known
yeah yes but detached from
anyone else really knowing you or seeing
you
there you go yes because it all does
anyway the it blends together anyway but
you have to go
all the way to the poll first and then
anyway as you shepherd people will
naturally as you
in matthew matthew 6 33
you first seek the kingdom of god within
and then all these fruits come to you
but you you go there first you focus on
the roots first
roots roots inside inside consciousness
infinity emptiness
transcend it all and then you get to a
point where
you shepherd so cleanly in service to
the one intelligence
that were any way fruits come but you're
so disattached from the fruits
that you don't let them trigger you into
any of your identifications
yeah yep yep yep for sure
it's like making money you don't need to
make money
you know you need to focus on yourself
and your growth and being true and
knowing where you're coming from and
guess what
if you do that long enough money is just
an inevitable result
it just comes you don't have to try for
it
you know it's almost a wasted effort
making money because there's no
reason for it there's no truth behind it
what is it good for
make self and money will come
and no matter what befalls my life
immediately i go to vibration
immediately
immediately
because that's all that matters that's
all that's required that's the only
thing that requires my attention another
richard condon saying what is the only
thing that requires your attention
your vibration
nothing else yeah that's great and then
the unfolding
is from there yeah yeah and i live that
i live that for sure i mean i've lived
that a long time just to hear him speak
that i was just like
yes nothing else matters
there's been a lot of
excitement in nls around
coming from that place of vibrational
wholeness and unity and bentino has been
pretty adamant about getting
us to focus on that vibrational state
and then having that unfold
all of the exterior circumstances
the more that you're whole and unified
and seeing the homogeneous existence
seeing intelligent infinity
the more that you come from that place
the more that you're
vibrationally it that it's locked in
that you're
getting it that you've got it that the
more that
unfolds from from this unit
of life itself and so from there
yeah yeah because the
energy you create within is what the
outcome will be
yeah as well so it has to be the same
yes yes yes it's all a mirror
in and out such a mirror yeah
collapsed into one yeah
and that's i see that happening in all
of the groups
definitely that coming together
from that undivided wholeness
it's happening and less efforting and
pushing and forcing
and making yeah
wow that's like the
the ideal is not having to
look over your shoulder not having to
like you mentioned do the
double checking where you're coming from
not having to feel fear to
say something into the field of the team
mm-hmm yeah but i think you have to
accompany that
with also
sort of a childlike glee for
maybe being called out and maybe
having a reflection of some impurity
it has to be that has to be just as
exciting
definitely and just as interesting
i mean we have to somewhat live for that
to a certain extent
if we truly want to become
purified then we have to look forward to
any and all ways that that could
potentially
happen yeah
that's it look forward to that you know
because then also when you're looking
forward to that
then you also have less of a chance of
censoring yourself
or being not being transparent
because it's it's okay be transparent be
honest be real
believe me you'll get all the feedback
you need yeah that was a good one
yeah those yeah just be real
i love the look forward to the
purification dissolving that shit's
funny like look forward to it like
get pumped about it yeah that's great i
love the get pumped energy about it
there's like such a taboo around um like
dissolving that and it's better to come
at it from
excitement of like all right
all right baptized by fire yeah yeah
let's
let's see what it's the same as fear
it's the same with fear
like to use fear as a marker that's how
i use it
yeah i mean unless there's a bear in
front of me unless there's a
imminent death in front of me
fear means do that
to me yes interesting that
yeah what am i most afraid of right now
that's my the next thing on my agenda
yeah yeah that's so interesting
it has to be
because then otherwise i'm avoiding and
otherwise then i'm coming from
fear i mean it's a place that i can
clearly
eliminate coming from there yeah yeah
clearly
so why wouldn't i just take myself up on
it
[Music]
this kind of boils down to also the yes
theory
seek discomfort i love that
mm-hmm but then again
but to the extent yeah yeah and then
don't be attached
yeah because when it's comfortable when
it becomes comfortable speak to
seek discomfort until it becomes
comfortable
there you go yeah that's it and then
don't necessarily seek it anymore
but instead revel in the freedom you
have to be in it or not
it's the same there you go yeah exhaust
the seeking and then
you can discern between when you're
abiding in the freedom versus when
you're contracting your energy
yeah and and also just knowing
that you can go anywhere to serve
that you're not combined in confined
quarters well i can
serve like this or i can serve like that
no you can serve
in any way that is called for because
you're not attached to anything
it's kind of funny like even after
transcending the paradigm of
spirituality itself
that there's still a purification
like even if you've exhausted
them yeah even if you exhaust the seeker
though which is like
that's like okay fine like it's time to
drop the secret because you like you get
spirituality you got it like
transcend the script that you've been
chasing the last couple of years like
you get it
but then the thing that remains is
purification
yeah that's what's funny that's the
thing that remains
it kind of goes on forever yeah
like it just goes on and goes on and
goes on and goes on you never come to
the last
you'll never come to the last expression
of infinity just like you'll never come
to the last conditioning of the mind
body spirit complex
that's just funny well literally thank
god for that
yeah it gives us a [ __ ] odyssey yeah
yeah exactly
that's a pretty cool it's a pretty cool
place to rap do you feel so
the witch sorry to wrap to close up
the show oh yes
my terminology you wanna rap girl let's
rap
wrap the show wrap this [ __ ] no i'm hot
no that's fine it's good
we i think we got some good
chit chat out there it was very good i
feel so honored to be
have been a part of it and i'm i'm so
happy to have met you
me too as well me too like really and
now
we're going to be working together yeah
it's cool to see what unfolds
yeah in what's unfolding and i really
recommend people to check out the links
in the bio to not only the no limits
society conversations playlists that we
were mentioning
but also the no limit society the link
is in the bio below go and check it out
it's such a cool
nice to be at all the things that andrea
was sharing with us
about getting it locking it in just
being real
all these types of things are like the
front and center
of so no limits
oh see i missed out on because we're on
zoom and we're not on the other thing
all those fancy little quotes that you
would put up on the screen there
hey she's got like she knows what we
yeah correct
i would have been putting all of them up
on stream yard if we were on that
platform for sure
oh i just love it i love it when you do
that because it sort of just slowly
quickly immortalizes that person
yes in that moment it grabs a snapshot
of
their brilliance and their genius and
their love
and their infinite self and it's just
beautiful and wonderful
yes it further encapsulates
the aroma or the firework and then it
further amplifies for the viewers like
oh there's that key bit
and then like yeah it sits in greater
it's great yeah i mean it acts
as so many like it serves as well in
such a great way
yeah no it's really lovable it's really
lovely i'm so happy that you
catch that that part's it's definitely
one of my favorite parts it's like a
live
distillation that's my favorite part i'm
not kidding
it's my favorite part i love it when you
do that because
cool you're so sweet it's just like a
tickle
you know it's just like oh he's going to
write that down he's going to
display that you know yeah
seriously he's so sweet oh you're so
sweet
you're so sweet so i like i like that as
well but anyway
this is back to that recognizing and
translating she's so
good yeah yeah yeah exactly
we'll have more we'll have more episodes
together where i'll get the opportunity
to do
the live um
yeah yeah yeah yeah of course yeah
oh that's perfect oh i love that
that's great okay well that's excellent
maybe
maybe i'll be able to um interview you
for my audience at one point ah
yeah we could also do we've welcomed
that on the show as well where
the conversation is
a little bit more flipped also from
you uh which and regardless it'll still
be a good dialectic
that's that's the yeah and yeah
yeah it's a play so it'd be good we
could definitely do that on
on the program as well or we could also
do that if you would like for
the channel or whatnot that
that you're building on on your end or
whatever whatever we end up unfolding
which
we don't even know what that's right
yeah all that stuff
or even just on a call i just have a
bazillion questions for you so
you know we'll get perfect perfect
all right thanks everybody for tuning in
we love you so much
super grateful we would love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode let us know your thoughts
about
getting it locking it in all this kind
of
yeah i love that i love that uh just be
real all those good ones and
like the video if it brought you value
helps the algorithm subscribe if you
have into the channel
share the video with people that you
know this would profoundly benefit
and check out the links in the bio below
to andrea's writing
she's got a lot of great writing on her
medium check out her instagram as well
that links in the bio below
and she's got a lot of great posts there
to check out
and check out the no limit society again
the
conversations playlist and also the no
limit society
link as well to the actual platform
all right that is a wrap
thank you thank you
thanks andrea you're welcome thank you
pleasure so grateful